en este vídeo quiero explorar la
siguiente pregunta he dado un segmento b
puedo construir un segmento a de tal
forma que la razón a / b le voy a poner
aquí a / b sea igual a la razón
además b / a
/ a es decir geométricamente quiero que
la longitud del nuevo segmento entre la
anterior sea igual a la longitud de la
suma de ambos segmentos entre la
longitud del nuevo segmento que pinte
bueno vamos a pensar por el momento que
sí que si podemos construir una que
cumpla con esta igualdad ya esta razón a
/ b le voy a llamar fi es la letra
griega fi minúscula vale bueno vamos a
ver algunas propiedades que debe tener
esta razón si por ejemplo una muy
sencilla se obtiene a partir de que a
más b entre a es igual a a entre a más b
/ ar
simplemente separa el numerador en estos
dos suman dos vale bueno pero a / a
es igual a 1 y b entre a pues bien entre
a es lo mismo que a entre b pero
volteado es decir es un inverso
multiplicativo o bien su recíproco y
como a entre bs pues b entre a es uno
entre phil éste es uno entre fin de esta
forma de esta forma lo que acabamos de
argumentar es que si lo voy a poner aquí
con color naranja
si es igual a 1 + 1 entre sí y esto está
padre porque por ejemplo si restamos uno
de ambos lados nos dice que menos 1 es
igual a 1 entre sí de forma que el
inverso multiplicativo de fisio tiene a
partir de fin simplemente restando 1 eso
está súper loco no pero bueno déjame
regresar a esta igualdad para escribir
otra cosa que también está súper bien
que nos dice lo siguiente mira voy a
poner fin
y si es igual a 1 1 en 3 y 1 más 1 entre
sí pero en vez de poner aquí abajo en el
numerador simplemente fin pues bueno ya
que pies uno más uno entre sí voy a
poner uno uno más uno en tres y uno
entre sí pero aquí abajo en vez de poner
si voy a volver a poner uno más uno en
tres y uno más uno / diego aquí podría
poner fin y se acaba la cosa pero no
vamos a seguir haciéndolo más
emocionante entonces en vez de ponerse
aquí pongo uno más uno en tres y uno más
uno entre sí pero una vez más y es uno
más uno en tres y entonces se ve que
podemos hacer esto indefinidamente
verdad le voy a poner aquí puntos
suspensivos va y entonces decimos que si
cumple una definición recursiva para una
variable en términos de sí misma y bueno
básicamente es que tiene esta expresión
en fracciones que se ve súper bonita
bueno hasta ahorita todo va muy bien
pero imagínate que queremos determinar
el valor exacto de fi es decir queremos
dar así numeritos que nos representen a
fin
bueno pues para eso lo que vamos a hacer
es transformar esta igualdad en una
ecuación cuadrática y para eso vamos a
multiplicar por fi de ambos lados de la
igualdad que es lo que nos queda pues
multiplicando por fi aquí y acá nos
queda que fi cuadrada y cuadrada es
igual a fi más 1 y sabes que déjame
hacer un pequeño paréntesis porque hay
otra cosa pues similar a ésta que
también es emocionante entonces antes de
determinar el valor de fi déjame
observar aquí al lado que fui entonces
es igual a la raíz a la raíz cuadrada de
aquí en vez de ponerle encima su no le
voy a poner uno más y entonces podemos
hacer un proceso similar o sea otra vez
una definición recursiva pero ahora
utilizando esta igualdad y que nos
quedarían nos quedaría que fin
es igual a la raíz la raíz d
uno más
y aquí hay que poner fin pero en vez de
poner si ponemos esta cosa entonces nos
queda la raíz cuadrada de 1 más otra vez
en vez de poner si ponemos la raíz
cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de uno más y
otra vez en vez de poner ponemos raíz
cuadrada de uno más y así podemos seguir
sucesivamente vale entonces aquí tenemos
otra pues otra igualdad que está bien
padre verdad este número que es el
número que al restarle 1 obtenemos su
inverso y que es el número que satisface
esta igualdad con fracciones también
satisface esta identidad con radicales
integrados bueno se está súper padre
pero bueno regresemos a esto en lo que
en lo que estábamos que era determinar
el valor de fin y decía que esto ya era
una ecuación cuadrática bueno déjame
pasar restando si más uno para que
realmente lo veamos en forma estándar y
entonces nos quedarían lo voy a poner en
color morado nos quedaría que fi
cuadrada y cuadrada menos fi menos uno
es igual a cero y ahora si ya tenemos
esto listo para utilizar la fórmula
general déjame pasarme aquí abajo
observa que el coeficiente cuadrática
uno es igual a uno el coeficiente lineal
es menos uno entonces b es igual a menos
uno y el término constante que ese es
igual a menos uno y por lo tanto podemos
utilizar la fórmula general para obtener
qué fin
no voy a poner aquí abajo que si a y
observa si debe de ser positivo porque
viene de un problema geométrico entonces
es una razón de cosas positivas y por
tanto es positiva pero bueno ahorita
vamos a ver por qué dije eso entonces si
es igual utilizando la fórmula general a
menos b o sea menos menos 11 más menos
esto es lo que nos dice la fórmula
general que la aprobamos en otros vídeos
la puedes probar completando el cuadrado
por checando los otros vídeos pero bueno
es menos b más menos raíz cuadrada de b
cuadrada que es uno menos uno al
cuadrado es uno menos cuatro por a por c
menos cuatro por uno es menos cuatro por
menos unos cuatro entonces sería más
cuatro y esto dividido entre dos a como
a es uno es dividido entre dos y esto de
aquí a que es igual esto de aquí es
igual a
si le ponemos menos vamos a restar la
raíz de 5 y nos va a quedar negativo
entonces tenemos que ponerle más es
igual a 1 + raíz de 5 y esto dividido
dividido entre 2 muy bien entonces ya
tenemos una expresión para fin ya
sabemos que fi es uno más raíz de 5
entre 2 y estoy aquí va a ser un número
irracional porque raíz de 5 es
irracional eso quizás lo pruebe en otro
vídeo pero por el momento vamos a
quedarnos con la idea de que su
expansión decimal no se repite no es
periódica y no termina vale
de hecho sabes que vamos a ver cuánto es
déjame sacar la calculadora debe estar
por acá aquí está la calculadora y vamos
a ver cuánto nos queda fin vamos a
aprenderla entonces tenemos que hacer
uno más raíz de 5 y eso lo tenemos que
dividir entre dos oyentes a lo mejor el
último dígito está mal voy a copiar
hasta aquí
bueno es que la calculadora luego
redondea pero voy a poner 1 puntos 61 80
33 98 a ver si me acuerdo de eso
entonces voy a tomar otro color
digamos blanco entonces si es igual a
1.6 18 10 33 0 33 98 si eso es lo que
había dicho la calculadora bueno y
puntos suspensivos verdad esto de aquí
otra vez es un número irracional
entonces su expansión decimal
nyse ciclo ni termina es decir no se
repiten y termina vale bueno entonces
aquí tenemos fin y bueno vamos a
regresar a esta igualdad para pues para
aplicarla de alguna forma
imagínate que ahora nos piden determinar
ósea ya sabemos qué es esto y nos piden
determinar uno en tres y uno en 3 y 1 /
déjame ponerle un poco más a la derecha
uno entre el recíproco def y este número
también se denota como fin mayúscula y
mayúscula vale entonces a lo mejor lo
puedes ver en la literatura así entonces
como le haríamos hay que sacar la
calculadora de nuevo pues no verdad
porque gracias a esta igualdad después
ya tenemos que que uno entre fiesp y
menos uno así que basta restarle uno a
esta expresión para ver cuánto eso 1 en
y uno entre sí es igual a 0.6 18 033 98
y puntos suspensivos entonces esto está
súper padre verdad ya vimos una
aplicación de esta fórmula para obtener
el recíproco simplemente este 1 lo
convertimos en 0 pero estas cosas se
ponen todavía más emocionantes resulta
que si él se conoce como la razón abre a
la razón dorada la proporción áurea la
proporción divina tiene muchos nombres
yo le voy a decir algunos de esos
digamos la proporción áurea y bueno
estos nombres tan especiales son porque
fije aparece por todas partes aparece en
el arte aparece en la música en la
naturaleza y es más te voy a dar algunos
ejemplos para que veas el tipo de ideas
puras en las cuales se aparece por
ejemplo si tenemos una estrella una
estrella regular de cinco picos también
se conoce como pentagrama resulta que si
se aparece por ahí voy a intentar
dibujarla lo más regular posible el
chiste es que los
5 los 5 lados queden iguales y los
ángulos también digo no me va a quedar
exactamente pero es es la idea entonces
ahí está entonces resulta que si se
aparece en esta estrella regular como si
aparece fin pues si llamamos a esta
longitud
y a esta longitud ve
resulta que a / b es igual a fin también
a b entre a es igual a pero claro eso es
porque así construimos y verdad sin
embargo si hay otros lugares donde se
aparece por ejemplo si este de aquí si
este de aquí es b si estoy aquí es b y
este de acá es a la caixa una vez más a
/ b es igual aquí o bien todo entre a es
igual a fin otra vez por la definición
también en los pentágonos con los
pentágonos regulares pasa algo similar
si aquí pintó un pentágono regular soy
muy malo dibujando pentágonos así que si
no me quedan muy bien espero que me
perdones pero bueno más o menos así se
vería un pentágono regular también los
pentágonos regulares se aparecen y donde
se aparece pues ahora como la razón
entre la es la longitud de una diagonal
la longitud de una diagonal y uno de los
lados vale entonces si éste es ay
estévez a / vuelve a ser fin entonces
fui sean apareciendo por todas partes
bueno al menos aquí en las figuras
geométricas de hecho hay otra figura
geométrica en la cual se aparece déjame
pintarlo porque este ejemplo también
está muy interesante y es en un
rectángulo entonces imagínate que vamos
que pintamos un rectángulo donde esto me
debe
de esto me debe y esto me deja esto me
deja entonces es un rectángulo en el
cual sus lados están en la razón áurea a
/ b más o menos es algo así vale bueno
resulta que si tenemos un rectángulo así
pasa algo bien interesante cuando lo
dividimos en un cuadrado y otro
rectángulo es decir cuando pintamos una
línea que hace que hace que esto me da b
si esto me debe entonces ahora esto me
debe menos a verdad no más bien mide a
menos ve aa menos b porque el lado total
está y le estamos restando b
aquí nos queda otro rectángulo que crees
que suceda con ese rectángulo de la 2a -
vive bueno pues vamos a calcular vamos a
calcular la proporción entre estos lados
a ver qué pasa vamos a ver cuánto es b
entre a menos ve lo voy a hacer aquí al
ladito vamos a calcular este b b entre a
menos a menos bueno pues esto de aquí es
igual a 1 entre aa menos b entre b si
simplemente pase la ve al denominador
entonces tiene que pasarse dividiendo
pero esto de aquí es igual pues entre bs
porque así construimos el rectángulo
original es uno entre fi y b entre b es
menos uno es uno entre fi menos uno pero
recuerda fíjese este número
superespecial que al restarle uno se
convierte en su red si preocupa entonces
esto de aquí es igual es igual a un 1
entre 1 entre sí y esto está súper padre
porque 1 entre 1 entre sí es igual a sí
entonces si partimos en un cuadrado de
un rectángulo este rectángulo chiquito
vuelve a ser un rectángulo
bueno así se conoce un rectángulo con
lados en proporción habria esto está
súper padre porque ahora podemos repetir
el procedimiento es decir ahora podemos
dividir este nuevo rectángulo en un
cuadrado y un rectángulo y este bueno
este cuadrado tiene cierta longitud pero
este rectángulo vuelve a ser un
rectángulo abrió podemos repetir esa
idea
otra vez partimos haciendo un cuadrado
en un cuadrado y un rectángulo áureo
podemos hacer lo mismo aquí nos queda un
cuadrado y un rectángulo áureo y ya se
ve la idea verdad que aquí podemos
seguir pintando cuadrados y rectángulos
abre los cuadrados y rectángulos saurios
y esto queda súper padre porque porque
si ahora sí ahora trazamos una curva que
vaya uniendo este patrón que son como
cuadrados que van girando y trazamos una
curva nos vamos a encontrar con algo
bien padre que a lo mejor has visto
antes
entonces déjame unir por acá este con
este luego este con este este con este
este con este y nos queda esta curva que
a lo mejor conoce si has visto en otros
lugares y bueno quizás el lugar en el
que más probablemente has visto esta
curva es en una concha de nautilus
entonces observa este este esta
construcción geométrica que tiene que
ver con fin por alguna razón se
relaciona con una concha de nautilus con
una espiral de la concha de nautilus y
bueno la razón no está también tan
misteriosa porque en el fondo así se
hacen las conchas de nautilus tiene que
ver con que cada una de sus capas se va
haciendo con cierta proporción pero está
padrísimo vaya aquí en la naturaleza
también se aparece esa proporción y esta
proporción áurea y aquí a la derecha
tenemos una pintura porque también si se
aparece mucho en el arte de hecho a
leonardo da vinci le gustaba muchísimo
utilizar aquí pero estoy acá no es de da
vinci si no es de salvarlo salvador dalí
y bueno déjame platicar un poquito de
donde aparece en esta en este lienzo de
hecho aparece por todas partes va a
empezar
el lienzo están en proporción habría lo
puedes checar y puedes a tomar las
medidas entonces este / este es igual a
sí pero si aparecen muchos otros lados
te recomiendo que flórez la pintura por
ejemplo en los lados de la mesa y las
distancias entre las personas pero
déjame darte algunos otros ejemplos más
por ejemplo aquí tenemos pentágonos y ya
platicamos como los pentágonos tienen
que ver con fin entonces ese es otro
lado donde se aparece fin al parecer a
dalí le gustaba mucho esta idea de la
proporción áurea y bueno finalmente otro
ejemplo que te puedo dar es que si nos
fijamos aquí donde terminan esta persona
si trazamos una línea dónde termina
pues justo resulta que aquí a la derecha
nos queda un cuadrado y bueno como el
primero en un rectángulo abrió una vez
más tenemos que este es un rectángulo
abrió entonces este lado déjame lo pinto
con un color más brillante este entre
éste vuelve a ser sí vale porque existe
entre este y este rectángulo abrió pero
bueno esto está padrísimo espero que te
haya gustado estas cosas que te conté y
vaya te invito a seguir explorando este
número que está súper interesante